das ukrainische Präsidentenamt meldet
Angriffe auf viele ukrainische Städte
Berichten zufolge ist es eine Serie von
Raketenangriffen unter anderem auf leviv
tenopil und Nitro das hier das sind
Bilder aus Kiew aus dem Zentrum und
mehrere schwere Explosionen gab es eben
auch hier wir sehen dicken schwarzen
Rauch über der Stadt gleich mehrere
Raketen sollen hier vor wenigen Minuten
erst eingeschlagen sein das berichtet
eben auch Cheops Bürgermeister Vitali
Klitschko seit Ende Juni gab es hier
keine russischen Luftangriffe mehr jetzt
wohl gleich drei laute Explosionen 15
Menschen sind verletzt es soll auch Tote
geben ja und zuvor gab es eben auch
Drohungen aus Russland denn Russland
macht ja die Ukraine für die Explosionen
auf der krimbrücke verantwortlich dass
ihr eventuell dann eben also ein
Gegenschlag uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt
Wladimir Klitschko der Klitschko was ist
genau passiert
heute früh sind mehrere mehrere oder
eine es ist schwer noch zu beurteilen
Explosion im Stadtzentrum in Kilo
Stadtzentrum mit
Rauch was zu sehen ist und natürlich
Fahrzeuge die
unter vorstehen man redet gerade über
die Zivilisten
verletzten oder getöten das ist noch
schwer zu beurteilen
es ist es ist kritisch gerade in der
Stadt er hört wahrscheinlich im
Hintergrund auch die Rettungsfahrzeuge
und Sirenen
das ist noch schwer zu beurteilen was
genau oder wie viel Raketen sind auf die
Stadt abgefeuert worden klar ist
statt oder Mittel des Stalls ist im
Rauch der Rest wird dann im nächsten
Minuten mehr geklärt
sie haben es gerade schon angesprochen
was können Sie uns denn zu diesem
Zeitpunkt sagen über mögliche Opfer über
Tote und Verletzte
noch schwer was zu sagen klar ist die
russische Raketen sind im Stadtzentrum
gelandet
in Stadtmitte gelandet
wie gesagt
Rauchwolken sind über das Stadtzentrum
genauso wie er vorher es ist noch schwer
zu sagen wie viele verletzten oder oder
getöteten sind aber klar ist der Angriff
auf die Stadtmitte ist schon passiert in
verschiedenen sozialen Netzwerken wird
berichtet dass ein Büro von Präsident
selenski angegriffen wurde was wissen
sie darüber
ich bin nicht der Bürgermeister von
Stativ ich bin Wladimir Klitschko mein
Bruder ist der Bürgermeister und
deswegen kann ich nicht kommentieren wie
die Aufnahme oder wie die beiden der
Bürgermeister von Stadt Kief und der
Präsident Ukraine miteinander in
Verbindung sind das kann ich nicht mehr
mit dir
man muss ja sagen der Krieg in Kiew der
Hauptstadt der Ukraine der China fast
ein wenig zu pausieren ist jetzt die
Angst in der Hauptstadt zurück
es war immer die das Ziel auch die
Hauptstadt anzugreifen und im Laufen
sieben Monaten des Krieges acht Monaten
des Krieges es ist schon zu sehen dass
Angriff ist auf ganze Land ist und
genauso gewesen
entweder sind das stresskräfte die
Soldaten die dann
Menschen umgebracht haben Zivilisten vor
allem umgebracht haben die russische
Soldaten oder Raketenangriffe die die
immer noch dauern also der Krieg läuft
und das der Krieg auf das ganze Land die
ganze Ukraine was meinen Sie es gab
Drohungen ist das die Rache für die
grimm-brücke
man kann das auch genauso beurteilen
dass sie die Rache Putins auf Creme oder
auf Grünbrücke wie auch immer der Krieg
läuft schon seit Ende Februar und es ist
ein unendliches Leiden
der Ukraine und es geht einfach weiter
vielen Dank für diesen Moment Vladimir
Klitschko live aus der Ukraine